hello and welcome to this video playing
SG 17 and she goes for this line I don't
really know I haven't studied this yet
to be honest in terms of a Petrov based
repertoire
yeah watching where you going Bishop c5
probably you know what White has decent
development but is this enough yeah
probably not
but in the context of a blitz game you
can often a sacrifice a pawn slightly
incorrectly and it's not going to be
that that easy to play we have good
pieces woodwind active pieces are
usually just in this kind of scenario
transposed to like here transposed to
scotch with 96 but there is no good if
you have a petrol based repertoire
probably Bishop before check us what you
should do but I really I'm not
knowledgeable down at all okay so what
to do
Bishop g4 is an interesting choice
you probably have six King takes 95
Queen g5 Queen b3 that's Bishop e6 yeah
that should be playable mmm still it's a
bit odd still Knight is 7 or Knight f6
Knight f6 but if I if I just stick with
the pawn yeah it doesn't really threaten
much the knight f6 must be right okay so
h6 I don't really see if five
threatening much it's my problem I mean
not my problem I mean it's what I don't
see like II five D takes you should be
okay so I can just castle okay then I
must be okay yeah
can't believe that this is this is a
good compensation for white not behind
in development 95 maybe you know but why
not why not keep the bishop yeah it's
it's a really nice piece down
okay now 95 of the same well obviously
is strong here why why actually why is
that obvious
I never discover it is quite obvious
using the pin and tempo yeah now 96
looks good yeah
he either has to give up before for
absolutely nothing or take on f6 which
is kind of admitting that he's just a
pawn down for four zip yeah and now I've
got the dark squares yeah this is
excellent okay nobody should pair for
you or I don't give it up let's let's
put it like that I'm happy to have it
and don't give it up now night night
will sit fantastically I think on a
hundred for there is no g3 anymore
Quan g3 it's not possible h3 is hanging
and I've got the really nice Bishop
won't be six that looks good
I'm just down on the clock spend much
time at the very beginning okay maybe I
didn't need that but let's stop it stop
the airport okay if four is attacked and
a normal move like Bishop d3 runs until
night f4 which looks excellent
maybe cause Bishop b5
possible okay
that's impossible not to play Knight f4
with a huge tempo Queen g6 now it looks
fine but I mean what is he doing next if
I just double like only if I'll he has
he has no good move really
there is no II five there is no g3 just
doubling him okay
96
no 96 he might have Knight f5 okay just
one day yeah it looks it looks really
odd like it shouldn't work at all
I'm gonna have to here but I came it's
just like it's not necessary really to
do anything fancy him and that doesn't
work
Knight takes care and now probably this
is easiest
yeah I don't know I'm not sure I mean at
the very beginning I'm maybe he has some
compensation for this but I mean there
is there's a reason why this is not
plate I mean Bishop before I think is
probably the reason if you could force
black into a pet into a scotch and avoid
the petrol or people would do it all the
time I mean not all the time but it
would be a serious option became the
chick
c-3po has to be played to make it
worthwhile and probably night takes now
iam maybe maybe you should just take
with the night it's a bit so now ya know
but what is this what kind of position
is that it's kids know transposition
right
96 for transpose into a girl in gambit
or girl in gambit always weird if you
have a German a name that is pronounced
in German way and I mean English mode
and I tend to do something really stupid
like pronouncing the German name in
English fashion which sounds totally
stupid but I do it involuntarily yeah I
don't know that that is kind of that's
no theoretical position probably on that
not very much explored so but back here
I should see for I am I mean he said
enough compensation like I don't believe
it
96 White has Tempe but yeah now tonight
g7 is actually given by the engine a
move that I have thought about but I
wasn't sure because of 95 ok but it
turns out that this is strong of course
yeah I was fearing this a little bit but
it really is no danger I am night 7 to
g6 I am and I'm threatening this very
nice and the bishop hangs ok ok when I
have 6 is that bad yeah the enemy wants
to go with 5 which is
well extendable if you somehow you need
to strike while the iron is hot and now
or never
but it's not enough him I was thinking I
would have taken with the pawn I think I
have thought I should be fine even with
my cheeks King takes down
yeah I've got just like this trick again
he played Bishop g5 and this this is
just too slow I believe the ship G 4G 5g
a g5 maybe but I like to develop my
pieces and yeah this is just not enough
after Bishop takes f6 you're kind of its
kind of admitting that you're just a
pawn down and have the reverse position
yeah quick 26 I thought about it I mean
I saw the move but I wasn't sure like
here if I really want to check on e4 it
looks I have a bit of the position has a
bit of a looseness to it Knight age 4
and I can go here actually which I
didn't really see him okay yeah so but
the red rook e7 is a goodness yeah you
just get the final pieces into play and
black you really have them which is
rotten and white is White's position is
just rotten it should be three as health
or but yeah interest just no good
yeah it's an odd line D 493 something
that that you have to study if you want
to play the petrov like I currently try
to do something that you need to have an
an idea against if you don't want to
transport us into a squat show or some
other line yeah thanks a lot for
watching